はい それからこのこれから仏教の輪廻の話なんです
今まではまあただ 俗世間の誰でも思ってる話と
それに対する反論 で ポイントはこれなんです
まだ覚えてますけど 一切は動的である
これで仏教の転生のの話が始まるんです
で このダイナミズムは適切んと
まあまあ これあんまり適切な日本語が見つからなかったんですけど
まあすべて動的であると
だから存在も動的なものであって
動くものであって 止まるものではありませんと
物質にも精神にも停止する瞬間はありません
これをお釈迦様が発見したものに
何一つも停止する 止まるっていうことはないんです
すーっと変わっている
これは移動するという意味ではありません
この変わるっていうことは
移動という意味ではありません
よく気をつけてほしい
移動とは変わらない何かが場所Aから場所Bへ動くことです
移動っていうのは 何か変わらないものがこちらからあちらへ行くことであって
ただの移動で別にどうったことないんで
そんなのは 仏教でいうというのは停止はない
停止はないっていうことはもう変わっていくんです
これは移動という意味ではありません
停止はないという時 あるものは常に変化しているという意味なのです
だから止まってない すーっと何だかんだも世の中で物質であろうが心であろうが
もうものすごい速さでスーッと変わっているんです
移動しているわけじゃないんです
変わっているんです 単純な移動とは複雑な変化を区別しましょう
移動っていうのはもう誰にでもわかる
子供にでもわかる もうバカバカらしいことでね
これは科学ではよく頑張ってます
移動のお話 移動論やらね
単純ですよ 計算もできるし
そんなものではない 変化っていうのは大変複雑です
だから区別してほしい
はい 移動は速度のことで
個体がないと成り立たない
移動っていうのは速度の話でしょ
速度の話 何かここからここまで動くんだよと
だから個体がない場合は移動は成り立たない
だから仏教では個体はないんですよ
ということは 科学世界で一生懸命計算している速度論は成り立たないんです
速度によって個体に影響を与えることはあります
それだけのこと たまに移動によって個体が変わる時もありますけど
そんなにもう大変なことではありません
これはもうアインシュタインやらね
そういう方々が言っているお話にまで同じことです
変化は移動がなくても起きていることです
この変化っていうのは
移動が関係なく常にすーっと変化もする
移動は別に勝手に移動したってもしなくたってもどうでもいいんです
変化はもう絶えず起こっているんだと
移動は空論で 変化は時間論なのです
空間論 空間と移動は空間論で
変化は時間論です 移動を考える場合は空間論で
これが皆様には移動は簡単にわかりますよ
大阪までどれぐらい時間がかかるかとかね
そんな話ですからね それは空間論ですよ
しかし 誰にもなかなかわからないのは
この変化論です これ 時間論なんです
これ 結構難しい 難しい句はないんですよ
人間考えたこともないんです
時間論は 科学やら学校でどこでも勉強しているのはもう空間論ばっかりなんです
ブッダは一切は変化しているという時間論を発見したのです
これがお釈迦様はもう発見した真理なんです
存在っていうのは移動論ではないんだと
空間論ではありませんと
変化論だよと なぜ発見かというと
皆様ご存知のキリスト教にしたっても空間論なんですね
点点と地があるとか なんとかなんとかとかね
全部空間論ですね 天国があるんだとか
ヒンドゥー教の空間論
ものすごく墨線があって
墨線の上に天国があって
墨線の一番下したいところで地獄があってとかね
そういうもう設計図ばっかり書いてるんです
地図ばっかり 地図ばっかり書いて
地図っていうのは空間論でブッダは地図書かないんです
変化ですから だからこれ
お釈迦様は修行している間でいきなりこれにひらめいたんですね
なんだ 今まで言ってること全部嘘じゃないかと
単なる移動論ではないかと
移動論というのはくだらない
何の役にも立たない すべて時間論でもう変化しているんだと
でもブッダの大発見なんです
で 個体の存在はまあ仮にですね
まあ私はちょっといい加減な日本語ですけど
まあ一時的なものです
これはあの移動論ではなくて
変化論から成り立つものですね
まあ例えば何かがあるといっても
あれは仮にあるだけなんですね
まあ例えば今このスクリーンに文字が映ってるんですけど
これ個体実体じゃないんですよ
ただ仮にそうなってるだけ
すぐ変わります もう早く変わってほしいと思っているかもしれませんけど
時間かかりますけど で
何でもほんの仮な一時的な存在
だから時間にやられます
時間が変わっちゃうと
もう違います 例えば花が咲いてるんだよと言っても
個体として花があるわけじゃないんです
どうしても個体として花があるというならば
まあ 1 日 2 日ぐらいでしょ
日本中いっぱい桜の花が咲いてるんだそうと言っても
まあせいぜい 3 日でしょうと
だから 3 日っていう時間がすべて支配しているんです
だから満開の日っていうのはたった 1 日だけでしょうに
だからすべてそんなもんで
個体の存在は一時的で仮なもの
取ろうとするともう変わっているんです
満開の桜を撮った途端にもう変わっている
もう満開ではありません
もう変わっています したがって
個体の探求は成り立たない
だから科学世界でやっている
この個体の研究 あんなのは成り立たないんです
個体はこれぐらい重い
これぐらい硬い これぐらい速いとか
あれやこれやと言っても
もうすぐ変わってしまうんですよ
まあこう例えば 例えば北極
北極でも南極でもいいんですけど
行ってもう 2万年の前の古い氷を持ってくるんだそうとか言って
自分の普通のカバンに入れて持ってくると
もう飛行機に乗っただけでもう変わっているんですよ
で これ 2 万年前 まあ一応凍ったままで持ってきたって
もうこちらに持ってくるともう変わってるんです
だから個体の研究っていうのは仏教は成り立たないものですと
まあ俗世間では成り立ちますけど
私たちのはもう桜の花ありますよということは
ただまあ言語上は言えますけど
それは単なる俗世間的なもので
実際のものではありません
そこで今の現象はどのように変化していくのかと
調べられます 個体の研究はできませんだけど
この今の一時的な個体が次にどうなるか
次にどうなるか 次にどうなるかという研究はできます
変化の法則も発見できます
それからどのように変化するのかとも発見できます
これもうちょっと説明しますけど
例えば種が植えたら次にどうなるかというと
芽が出る 次にどうなるかでも葉っぱが出るとかね
次にどうなるかというと
また伸びてくるとかね
いろいろその過程はわかります
でも本物の場面にいつでしょうかっていうことはないんですよ
ずっと変わるだけで それでもう植物大きくなっちゃって
また花が咲いて また実って
またゆっくり枯れて消えてしまう
だからずっと同じスピードで変化するんだから
どんなコマ どんな場面でも
もう絶対的大事な場面ではありません
そういうことで変化の過程は勉強できます
この変化の過程を勉強することで
どのように変化するか
なぜ変化するのかという因果法則は出てくるんです
で 宗教家の俗世間も現象個体の研究をする
だから宗教家と科学者は同じことをやっているんです
個体の研究をやろうではないか
でも個体は消えちゃいますけど
正確に言えば人偏の個体です
どちらどちら  個体っていうのの字は人間について
うん いえ この場合は一応どちらでも入るようにと考えましたけどね
パーティクルっていう意味ですか？粒子ではない
そんなものでもないんです
ただの俗世間の個体 もうすごい単純な個体っていう意味でね
だから花も個体で リンゴも個体っていうことで
米も個体でご飯も個体でした
我々は米の研究をする
ご飯の研究をするとかいうことをよくやっています
宗教家も同じことをやっているんです
したがって 何の結論にも至らない
だから見事にそれになってますよ
いくら科学が研究し続けても結論がないんですよ
だってすぐ変化するものの研究だから
次なる変化ありますからね
次の個体の現象の研究しなくちゃいけない
どこまでやるのかと 無限に変化するんだから
無限に研究するんであって
結論には至らない それで宗教の世界でも
あれやこれやとか 言うは言うは言うは言うは一人も結論を出してないんです
もう異論ある 意見はあるわ
反対意見があるわ もう宗教の世界
争いばっかり そういうわけなんです
イスラムの人々は アメリカ人が悪魔のサタンの教えを信じているんだそうと言って
向こうはごちらがサタンやと言っていて
どこまでそういう言い張りやりますかと
どこまで行ったっても何の意味もないんですよ
仏さんが自分もアッラー
ジェホワ神様を守ってるんだから
もう戦争に勝てるんだそうと
もうイラク人やらアラビア人が
自分たちは唯一の神様を信じてるんだから
自分たちは勝ちますよと
もう思っておった結果はお互いに殺し合いやってるだけで
だから宗教の世界も結局個体論だから結論がない
本当に誰なのかと 神っていうのは
ジェホワですか？アッラーですか？アウルマッダですか？ブラフマですか
それぞれ名前変わると性格まで変わるでしょ
アッラの性格とジェホワの性格はすごく違うんだから
だからもうわからないんですね
結論は至らないんです
宗教の世界では で 至った結論あるとしても
仮のものです すぐ変わります
例えばもう科学者でもね
何か結論作るんだけど
すぐ変わります 科学では別に問題はありませんだけどね
それはもう分かりきったもので
今発見したものは次にまた変わる可能性あるっていうことは知ってますけど
宗教でもそれ見事に起こるんですよ
次から次へと教えが変わるんです
だから何を信じればいいんでしょうかね
まあわかりやすい皆様が知ってるのは
ほとんど宗教ではキリスト教だと思いますけど
もうジェホワっていうのは人がね
旧約聖書の性格を見てみると
もう変わるわ変わるわ変わるわ
自分が何者かわからなくなっちゃうんです
そこでイエス様の話から見ると
もうあまり出てこない
神ってどんな人かということは
それからのキリスト教はすーっと発展していったんだから
いろんな概念があるんですよ
だからどちらでしょうかと
その時その時何かを決めちゃって
それで人々をいじめるだけ
あのイスラム教の場合は
このジハドということは聖書で認めているんだと
コーランで だから人を殺す
自爆したっても大丈夫やと
別な天国は用意してやるんだと
一部は言って自爆テロをやる
私はコーランを読んでみたら
これジハドは成り立たないんですけど
ジハドっていうのは自分との戦いなんですけど
それだったら立派ですけど
そんなこと言っちゃうと私の恋も飛んじゃいます
サタンの教えを信仰する人は
コーランは読んだらもう目を奪わなくちゃいけないんだぞとかね
大変なことになるんです
解釈はそちらするんだよと
そこで最近 どこでした？インドネシアどこかでイスラムの学者を集めて
やっぱりジハドは認めませんと
自爆は良くないとまた言ったりする
好き勝手じゃないんですかね
だから いくらかアメリカ向きのイスラムのこの国はジハドには反対し
アメリカには断固と反対しているイスラム国々はジハドは賛成だと
どちらですかね 正しい真理は
だからこの空間論でいくと
個体の研究すると そうやってもう次から次へと結論が変わって変わっていく
変わっていって その当時の人々をいじめる
不幸にする それがまずいなと思ったら
また新しい考え方を出しちゃって
またいじめたりする あの初期時代の王たちが
自分たちが地球の王様であると
神の誰かでもあると だから何やっても大丈夫やと言って悪いことばっかししかやったことはないんです
普通 聖書で人殺しはいけないとあるのに
軍隊を持って人殺しに行くんです
ほう 信じられないほど恐ろしいことをやってきたんです
もうそろそろ最近ですよ
もういくらか人間になったのは
おそらくこの今の人からかな
まあそんな人いろいろやりましたけど
だから まあもうこの解釈
定義 結論っていうのはね
やっぱり困るんですよ
人間が反対すると 例えばロマ法王たちがもう女遊びっていうのはやりたい放題
しかし カトリックの神父さんなんかは
もう神父辞めても結婚してはいけないんだと
あなたはもう結婚も結婚しない約束は永久的に神にした約束だよと平気で言う
自分の国でもある神父さんがある女の人に恋をしちゃって
これ 結構仏教の国だから
もう結構話題になってしまったんです
で 何でおかしいことをやるんでしょうか
その神父さんがすごい立派な正直な人で
そうですと で 自分がもう女
私はとできているんだと
だから教会ではそれをやってはいけないというならば
私は神父をやめて その人と結婚したいんだと言って
それを出したんですよ
それでローマ教会は何を決めたかというと
神父をやめることは認める
しかし 一生結婚は認めません
だから私だったら あなた方は何やってきたんでしょうかと
ずっと流れで あなたもあなたもあなたもあなたも
あなた方だけやっている
冗談じゃないぞと言えばいいのにね
まあ彼が何やったかわかりませんだけど
だからこの何やと こうやってね
もう宗教の世界にしたっても
ごちゃごちゃごちゃでしょ
もう政治にしたって もう何でもごちゃごちゃなんですね
何か結論が出るんだけど
後で変わってしまう そこで困るのは我々なんですよ
今  NHK で夜遅くなんか
あのその時の世界 なんとかという番組を見ていたんですね
第1戦争  第2次世界戦争
もう日本人のもうロシア攻撃
中国攻撃 あれやこれやとかね
信じられないんで ここまでやるんでしょうか
ヒットラーがどうやって現れて
何をやったかとかね ムッソリーニは何々とかね
アメリカはどういう態度
すべて見事に もうすごく情報
すごくなんて言いますか
この偏ることなく 淡々と事実を流してますけどね
びっくりするんですよ
もう当時の人々はいかに苦しめされたかと
いかに嘘ついて騙されたかと
そこで現代世界に私は頭を引っ込させて考えたら
現代世界でも同じことをやってますけど
今情報が発達しているんだから
インターネットやいろいろあるんだから
もうすぐバレちゃうんだけで
バレてもやっぱり権力者が自分のいいことで言ったことで突き詰めていくんですよ
それで一般人が騙されて騙されて
困って搾取されていじめられて
すーっと終わっちゃうんですよ
だからそういう不幸なことはありますよ
この空観論の世界では
はい 変化の過程を調べると変化の仕方が見えます
だからリンゴの研究するんじゃなくて
リンゴはどうなるでしょうかと見てみるんです
赤ちゃんを砕いて研究するんじゃなくて
赤ちゃんという今一時的な物体が
個体がどうなっていくのかと
この過程をじっと調べてみるんです
この個体が瞬間だけだと
次は別なものであると
その過程を見ると このどのように変化するかということが見えてきます
それは因縁論です それで仏教で因縁論というものができているんです
変化の過程と変化はどのように起こるのかという
物質にも変化と因縁論が適合する
因縁論というのは物質にもあります
仏教はやります それを科学者に任せているんです
物質はあなた方はやってくださいと
生命は物質と精神の これから生命の話
生命というのは物質と精神の集合体ですよ
私 私というのは物質 もう地球からもらった物質と精神というものは 2つ合体して命というんですね
物体は体と言える 所縁は唯縁は精神
心の働きなのです これ
日本語わかりにくいだけで
この椅子も物体なんです
机は物体なんですよ でも命ではありません
私も椅子と同じく物体ですけど
生きてるんです 違うところは
私に精神というか心というか
何でもいいんです 言葉は
心が働いているのです
だから命 命といえば物体に心があるという意味なんです
難しくないんですよ そうやってこの単純で考えれば
命って何ぞやと なんのことない
物体に命 心がある それだけ
それだけのこと で 心も無停止で因縁によって変化する
物質は変化するということは
物理学を勉強した方々は知っている
で 心も無停止で止まることなくすっと変化している
だから この体の中で変化の流れは 2つあるんです
物体の変化の流れと心の変化の流れ
それから体と心がじーっと合体して動いてます
だからといって心は自分のスピードを下げることはしませんし
物質も自分のスピード下げたりすることはしません
スピードはちょっとバラバラなんです
はい 物質と同じく心も無限に変化する
そこで物質の変化も無限でしょうに
ビッグバンから始めたと言っても
それからビッグバンチになっちゃって
またまた繰り返しますよ
そんなのは終わりがない
物質に終わりがなく変化するんだったら
なんで心だけは終わりがあるんでしょうかね
ありえないんですよ だから私という物体を見ると
明らかに心という働きがあるでしょう
すごいエネルギーでしょう
歩くことも心ですから
私と同じ等身大の人形を作ったってのも歩かせませんし
大変でしょうし 歩かせるのも
でも私は簡単に歩けますよ
それは心なんですね それもエネルギーなんですよ
それが死んじゃったら消えますよっていうのは
あまりにも変な考え方なんです
証拠がなくて 信仰でエネルギーは消えません
だから体も体で勝手に変化するし
心も心の勝手で無限に変化する
どちらでも 心は物質を管理支配するから
一時的な物質現象が壊れても
体というのはそれは体ですね
心も壊れてしまう必要はありません
そこでこれ 仏教の考え方なんですね
心が物質を支配管理しているんだと
これわからないではないんですよ
この建物 誰が作ったんですかね？人間の心なんです
これは養老先生がね すべて意識の世界だと
人間が意図的に意識でいろんなことを考えて
もう計画立ててやろうとしているんだと
意識しかもう何もないんだと
自然なんかは人間にわからないんだとも言ってるし
まあそれはその通りの話で
この建物を作ったのは人間の心なんですよ
心があるんだから 大工さんの手が動いたんです
心があったんだから 設計図が設計描いたんです
それで心があるんだから
大工さんの手が動いたんで
だから物質はが心に支配されているということは難しく考えなくてもいいんですよ
なんでこの東映バスにすごい田舎の宣伝があるんだと
東京都なのに 富士サファリパークやらいろんな宣伝があるでしょ
バスなんかには心ですよ
誰かさんがこちらに宣伝書いて金もらおうではないかと思ったところで
もうそれなりに綺麗な宣伝がついている
だから明らかに誰かの意識が環境変わってるんでしょ
誰かの意識によって だからこの物質はもう心
心が物質を支配して管理していると理解した方がいいんです
仏教はそんなに 科学的な知識が要りません
お釈迦様がそこら辺の農民の方々やらおばあさんたちに説法したんだから
当時でね みんな悟り開きましたからね
そんなすごい知識は要りません
単純に考えればわかります
本当の真理は はい それでこのアルファもオメガもない時間
これは輪廻ということなんです
こういうタイトルというのはいろいろ考えてつけたんです
私はアルファでオメガであるとある人が言ってるんだからね
仏教から見れば よくわかります
あんたは輪廻ですよと
アルファもオメガもない時間ということで
時間ですね 空間ではありません
輪廻 物質と同じく心も無限に変化する
もう読むだけで十分だと思います
心は物質を管理支配するから
一時的に的な物質現象が壊れて
これ読んだって 一切のはい
一切の無常を発見したところで
深夜中生命の輪廻も釈尊が発見なさったのです
で お釈迦様がこの菩提樹の下でずっと瞑想していて
あらゆるものは変化しているんだ
こういうことで変化しているんだと
これはこういうわけで
これ因縁論とかもう全部発見したんです
悟ったんです そこで深夜ぐらいになってくると
なるほど 輪廻ってあるんだと
転生ってするんだと こういう無常論によって
だって心が切れませんだから
続くんだから 発見したんです
発見したところで それから実例調べたんです
本当にそうなのかと まず自分にはどうやって自分が過去でこの心が変化していたのかと調べて発見して
それから自分だけだったら科学的な証拠になりませんだから
あらゆる生命をモデルにとって
この生命は過去どうなったか
過去のどうなったかと見て
見て 見て 見て 無数に調べて
それでチュトゥーパパティナーナという智慧が現れたんです
結構研究したんです 瞑想
だから仏教でいう転生はブッダの発見なんです
そこら中の一般の人々が言ってる話ではないんです
それにはもう断固断固反抗していますからね
これはもう時間論の話なんです
無常論の結果なんです
それで これは単純に終わりなく変化するという話なのです
だから輪廻転生というのは何のこともない
単純に考えれば 物事は終わりなく変化するんだなという話なんです
それぐらいの理屈 理解あれば十分仏教的な輪廻なんです
物事っていうのは もう私もそうでしょうし
自分の気持ちもそうでしょうし
終わりなく回転するんだと
だからもう飽き飽きするんですよ
もうどこまで回転するのかと
はい １９に行きます それで輪廻ということで
しかし 一時的な現象に知識は引っかかっている人々にとっては
人々にはとても理解できないようです
この輪廻転生っていうのは
一般人にはなかなか理解できない
なぜかというと この現象に引っかかっているんだから
リンゴに引っかかっているんだから
私は本当に死んだら生まれ変わるのと言った途端
私というこの一時的な現象に引っかかっているんですよ
どうったことない 今私というあなたが
1時間経ったら別な人だよと
1 日経ったらものすごく別な人だよと
そういう話 輪廻の話なんです
止まるなく 止まりなく変化する
そこでみんな聞きたがるのは
本当私が生まれ変わる
その私って何ですかね？これ成り立たないんですよ
これ個体だから 個体論は最初から成り立ちません
それを科学者がやればいいんです
結論もない だからリンゴの研究するんじゃなくて
リンゴはどうなるのかという研究であって
私は生まれ変わるんでしょうかという考えるんじゃなくて
今の瞬間の私と次の瞬間の私ってどうなってるんでしょうかと
その過程を研究するんです
私が生まれ変わるというような問題を考えるのです
これ本当なのかと それは何の答えも出せない疑問なのです
だから答え論で言っちゃうと結論がないんですよ
科学と宗教と同じ だから私は本当に輪廻転生するのかといっても
わかりますよ そんなことは答えがないんです
個体論です 時間論じゃないんです
時間論なら変わるだよと
あんたは ただそれだけやと
それだけのことであんた変わりますよ
だから私のこの話 もし聞いていたならば
それにも心が変わっていくんですよ
心が変わると体も変わりますよ
だから こちらに座った方々は
最初に立ってはいけません
別な人間になっているんです
不思議でもなんでもないでしょうね
それだけの話ですよ 輪廻転生っていうのは
死後でも同じことですよ
何のことなく変わり続く
で 仏教は心も限りなく変化しつつなのだという話なのです
個体の転生は邪見です
個体があって移転するんだそうと言えば
これは邪見 考えてみてな
とんでもない恐ろしい考え方なんです
だったら人を殺せますから
魂は殺せませんでしょうに
だったら殺してる人ということになります
すごい危険で邪見なんです
だから移転論ではありません
変化論です はい で 心は瞬間で別な心に変わるのです
ですから 生命は瞬間 瞬間で死と生を繰り返しているのです
心は瞬間で死んで新しい心が生まれます
今も だから今も我々は生と死の循環で生きているんです
生と死 生と死 生と死っていうこと
今も転生しているんです
輪廻転生 俗世間でいう体が壊れる死はそれほど大胆なことではありません
この物体に引っかかっちゃって
体が体が自分だと思っているんだから
えらい勘違いですけど
もう赤ちゃんの時から自分の体ってどれほど変化しているかと
どちらの体が自分ですかね
体が自分と思ってはいけないんです
そう思っちゃうと 転生するってかのおじいさん
おばあさんでしょ 転生するのは
最悪なんです 体がもう勝手に壊れるだけのことで
心は瞬間瞬間死んじて生まれて
死んじて生まれて 死んじて生まれて変化していくのです
体もじわじわと壊れていくのです
遺体の死はゆっくり起こるものです
体はゆっくり死んでいきます
例えば人が死んでも 遺体はまだ残っているでしょうし
それはゆっくり壊れていきます
仏教はもう明らかに見える
死はもう土になったところで終わりと
そこまで言うんで それは体の
心の死はまた別 心の死は瞬間で起こるのです
だから仏教には死  2つあります
体が壊れてゆっくりと土に戻る過程と
心の死と 心の死は瞬間
瞬間 瞬間 瞬間 今も起きています
はい それで死と生ということ
今の体の中でも心は瞬間的に生と死を繰り返している
体が壊れたからといって
この流れは変わることなく起こり続くのです
で 体と心っていうのは別々の働きだから
心がいつでも生死 生死
生死 生死で流れているんです
これは止まりません この後からつけた体が壊れたっても
この生死生死は続くんです
その時 その時の心の状況に応じて宿る体は変わるのです
で 心は何か体を拾って宿っちゃうんですよ
その時その時で変わるんですよ
これ今も起きてますよ
今も私たちの体が心の変化によって変わっていくんです
ずっと 例えば 何の苦しみも感じない
何のストレスもない もう明るくて元気でいる心を持ってる子供の体っていうのは
結構頑固で頑丈で もう壊れてもすぐ治る
結構動ける しかし もうあらゆる苦しみで悩んで
ものすごく重くなってる我々の体はどうですか？なかなか動かない
動かそうとしちゃうと
どこかで骨が折れたり
何とかなる 気をつけないと
私たちは階段で足でも滑っちゃうと
もう何ヶ月間の大怪我ですけど
子供が滑っちゃうと あっ
ちょっと傷がついただけで終わっちゃうんです
だから体がなんで今も変わってます
心がいつでも自分の体を作ってるんです
それで死んでからも その時の心がそれなりの勝手に体が作るんですよ
今も起きてる出来事なんです
そんな大胆なことでもないんです
今も心が体を作っているし
これはこの体がもう使えないものになっちゃうと
それ捨てちゃって それなりの別な体が作る
だから体捨てた瞬間で心が弱くなっちゃうんです
だから初めからもうスタートしなくちゃいけないんです
物質を作って 作って 作って
作って だからおばあさん死んでもおばあさんで生まれ変わるわけじゃないんです
はい 今の瞬間でも心によって体が変わり続けるのです
次にいきます えっと これには仏教専門用語でサンティティというんです
流れ 流れっていう意味です
生と死の流れ  生と死と流れです
パーリ語でサンティティという話です
で 流れって何なのかと
私はできるだけ単純に書いてます
種があると 次は葉でも花でも実でも幹でもなく
芽なのです 当たり前の話ですよ
種があったら次は芽ということ
心の流れの場合も 今の心が消えたら次に現れる心は何かと知ることができる
それできますよ 今の心がこんな状態だったら
次はどんな心なのかと
種から突然花が咲くわけないでしょうに
流れっていうのはそうやってすごく規則正しく
法則に則って流れていくんです
だから 例えばあまりにも俗っぽく考えるとわかりませんから
ものすごくこのもう激怒している人は
あまりにも怒りの激しさにもう体も震えていて
いても立ってもいられない状態でいる人は
瞬時に笑うと思いますか？お腹が抱えてゲラゲラとできません
あの激しい怒りの心というのは
じわじわと流れていって
それから笑う心を作るためには時間がかかります
時々悩んでる人々の悩みをなくしてあげようと思ったって
何年もかかるでしょう
瞬時に変わりません で
私は瞬時に変えて見せますけど
それはある特定の法則を知っているんだから
心の もう具体的に言えば
あれはショックトリートメントなんです
心の流れにいきなりショックを与えてあげても
別な回転にスタートされるんです
これはもう普通はできないと思いますけど
結構知らないと でないと
子供が死んじゃったって泣き崩れている人はもうこれ何年も泣きますよ
それでゆっくりゆっくりデータを与えて与えて
明るい心にしてあげなくちゃいけない
仏教の輪廻は普通な当たり前の考えであって
無常を理解できれば簡単に成し遂げる成り立つふくろんなのです
あれは即決するんであって
別にこれこそ決するってわけではないんです
無常を分かれば大丈夫です
だからヴィパッサナー瞑想とか何とかさせて
何をさせてるかというと
無常を発見させちゃうんです
無常を発見するというのは全部わかるんです
はい 多宗教と同じ概念かと
だから仏教の輪廻は多宗教の輪廻は同じじゃないです
ではありません 多宗教では個体の移動を考えたのです
移動なんかはあり得ない
個体は一時的なので 移動しようとするときも変わっているのです
移動する時も変わってるんです
だから移動論ではないんです
ここで死んで別なところに生まれ変わる時
その新しい生命は過去のものとは同一でも全く別でもありません
移動論じゃないんだから
変化論だから変化だから
過去のものとまるっきり同じではないんです
例えば 種と芽がまるっきり同じじゃないでしょう
芽を見ると種とは随分違うように見えるんだけど
種と何の関係もありませんということも言えません
だから同一でもないし
別々でもない 流れという言葉なんです
個体はサンペテっていうことなんです
それは有名なミリンデ
ナーガセーナ長老が使っている言葉
ネチッソネチャンニョーという言葉なんです
英語に訳すればノッティノットアナザーボディという訳になりますけど
同一でもありませんし
別なものでもありません
だから そこが本物の輪廻転生の話なんです
わからないと思うならば
これ無常を理解してほしいんです
無常論 移動論ではなくて
この無停止論 物事はダイナミズムですーっと変わっているんだから
変わることにはストップはないと
それ理解すればはい 個体として我
霊 魂など何かを信じる宗教家の転生論は事実無根の推測なのです
この我やら魂やら霊魂やら
何か主体があるんだぞというのは事実無根の推測なんです
それはアヨーニソマニシガラです
仏教から見れば変な思考です
アヨーニソマニシガラっていうのは
だって アッパヤリ 先見的に先見的な思考で
何か勝手に考え方を作って
その上建てるんじゃないんだよ
まずそれは正しく調べなくちゃいけないんだ
輪廻は無常という普遍的な真理そのものを別な言葉で言うだけです
だから輪廻っていうことは
仏教で言えばサンテティということなんです
これはおそらく日本語は流転ということでしょうね
流転なんか気に入らんですけどね
流転って言ったって 何か個体
が回るということになりますからね
個人の移動 再現ではありません
決して私という個人が来世まで移動するわけじゃないんです
引っ越するわけではありません
個人は今も事実として成り立っているわけではありません
個人という私が今もいませんよ
今もいない私はどうやって転生するんですかね
だから物の変化しかないんです
心の変化しかないんです
はい なんで変わるのかと
なんで無停止で物事変わるんですかね
まず物質で物質の中に熱
まあ仏教語ではアポというんですけど
という物質があります
これが物質現象を変えるのです
どんな物質の中にもアポという物質があって
それからの仕事は変えることなんです
物事は変えちゃう 別に難しくない
熱で変わるんだそうと
だからなんで卵持ってきて冷蔵庫に入れるんですかね
熱がないでしょうに だから蒸します
そんな話ですよ 変わると新たに熱が生まれる
でも残念なことに 物事を熱で変わると熱が生まれるんです
そうするとさらに変わるんです
で さらに新しい現象も変わってしまうのです
熱なしでは最小の物質も合成しません
それで最初のこの素粒子とかパーティクルとかという最初のものを合成するためにも熱が必要です
だからもう変わることはもうどうにもならない
熱抜けちゃうと物質ではなくなっちゃうんです
だから小さい花粉っていうのはいつでもワンセットで絶対離れないんです
ですから変わることは絶対的なのです
熱は物質を支えつつ変化させるものです
熱っていうのは物質を支えつつ
さらに変化させる だって我々は熱で生きているでしょうに
体に 同じく熱のおかげで老化して死んじゃうんです
はい それから心に 心は業で変わる
心に業という何か入っちゃって
これで心が限りなく転換する
変換する 業は普通用語で用語です
業っていうのは一般人の言葉なんです
専門用語ではないんです
仏教で 実は意志なのです
専門用語は意志というものなんです
チェータナ もろもろの感情によって
認識によって意志も変わってしまうのです
意志自体もずっと変わるんです
で 業の業は心のポテンシャルだと理解しても良いです
です 業によって心が変わると
新しいポテンシャルが生まれる
それでまた変わるのです
だから 心に何かポテンシャルがあって
どうしても変わらずにいられないんですよ
我々は何か知りたくていつでもたまらんでしょう
何かしたい 何かしたい
それなんですよ だから不安定なんで
心は それでも限りなく変わる
何かすればするほど さらに何かしたくなる
終わりがない だから業っていうのはずっとあって
心が回転する だから業っていうのは俗語で心理の言葉ではないんです
だからチェータナという言葉は本当に心理学的な言葉なんです
はい それからまあまとめて終わりなく変化
心も物質も終わりなく変化し続くのです
命とは物質と心が集合体になっていることです
またまとめです 心はそちらの法則で変化していく
心には心の変化法則があって
それによって変化する
転生とは体が壊れても心は自分の変化をすることです
だから仏教でいう転生
輪廻転生っていうのは
物質は壊れても 心には勝手な自分の法則があるんだから
それによって変化するんだっていうこと
心と体が同一のものであるならば
転生はあり得ない もうちょっと議論立ちます
もし心と体っていうのは同じものやと言うと
転生は成り立ちません
だって体どうなるかわかっているでしょう
そうすると転生は成り立ちません
はい 次 心は体の副産物であるならば
転生は成り立たないのです
また ある学者の方々は
科学者の方々は 心っていうのは脳細胞やら体の副産物やと
心はないんだ そう それが正しければ
転生はもう成り立ちません
仏教は間違っていることになります
仏教は心と体が別々なもので説明する
仏教は最初からもうこれは別々なものであると知っているんです
さらに すべての支配者も優先者も心だと説くのです
科学者がそう言うんだけど
仏教にまだチャレンジしていないんです
だから私たちはチャレンジするまで待ってるんです
したがって 天象は自然の法則になっている
心は別な働きだから 天象もごく自然な働きです
我々の仕事は心は別な機能かと調べることです
だから皆様にも課題があります
本当に体が心ですか？あるいは体と別な働きでしょうかと調べてください
自分も体ですから 自分の心ですから
それで別な働きと発見すれば
天象はもう成立しないです
はい しかし 心は体から独立して機能した経験はほとんどないので難しいでしょう
自分の心を観経すればいいんだけど
私たち知っている限りの私たちの経験っていうのは
体で来た経験でばっかりだからね
ちょっと難しいんです
無理わけじゃないんです
今の知識のすべては五感から得た物質的な情報なのです
我々の知識は物質の知識なので
心を知ることはたやすいことではないみたい
だから私たちの知識っていうのは物質
知識です 五感から得た情報だから
だからそこはいくらいじっても出てこないんです
だから科学者やってる同じやっちゃいけません
科学者は物質ばっかりいじって
心はないんだぞと言うんであって
やり方が違うんです だから私たちの知識
すべて物質 知識なんです
心の知識じゃないんで
だから瞑想でもして心は何なのかと見てみると
ああ 物質知識よりも心は回転するんだってことはもういとも簡単に発見できますよ
ヴィパッサナー瞑想やれば
だいたい 2 日間ぐらいでこれぐらい発見できます
我々の外のみ見る癖をやめて
内も見てみれば 心の法則の発見できるのです
はい 次に行きます これで終わりなき変化
えーと ちょっと文字が違ってますね
英語勝手に入りますね
これ これ 因果法則のある一行なんです
ウィンヤーナパッチャナーマルーパ
色により名色が生じるという
色ってのは心 名色の名はまた心です
色は物質です 生命です
体です だから色が次の色で生まれると同時に体作っちゃうんです
そこで難しいことは ナマルーパッチャウィンヤーナなんです
名色により色が生じる
体と心から心が生まれるという
この相互関係なんですね
心と体と 相互依存関係がこの問題の理解を妨げているのです
これちょっとあまりにも難しすぎ
ここら辺は  これは一応サーリプッタ尊者の分野で
サーリプッタ尊者がそこら辺は説明しているところで
そこからちょっとちょっと隠っちゃったんですね
一応みんな我々の世界で理解するのも
やっぱり我々から考えれば
体と心はどうしても離れないように感じがするんです
それはこの相互依存の問題で
色 心が体と心を造る それで体と心を作った命がまた心を作るという
はい なぜ過去を覚えていないのかと
いくらなんでも過去はあるというならば
将来はわからないんだから
わからないんだからね
将来はまだないんだからね
覚えるならば過去はない
なんで覚えないのかと
私たちは自分の過去を覚えているならば
輪廻ぐらいあると理解できる
皆様方 自分の過去を知っているんだったらね
今まで苦労は要りませんしね
しかし 現在のこともろくに思い出せません
過去のところから心に意識化できる量があるみたい
我々の心にあるいくつかしか意識化できないんですよ
弱すぎる 何だかんだ思い出しちゃうとどうなるかわからなくなっちゃうんですよ
自己管理できなくなるんです
だから このやたらに過去を思い出すということは
瞑想してしっかり人格を作った人以外はやっちゃいけないことなんです
心に記憶は何かと別に理解しなくてはならない
その記憶と思い出す法則は別なテーマで我々は勉強しなくちゃいけない
記憶って何なのかと なんで何か覚えて何かを忘れちゃうんですかね
そこら辺ですごい深い学問があるんです
仏教でなくても 世の中の普通の心理学でも
そこら辺はね 大体このインパクト強いものだけ覚えてる
幸福であろうが不幸であろうが
インパクトが強い いわゆる業が強い
ポテンシャルが それは忘れませんね
それからわがままで自己中心で都合に悪いものはあえて忘れる
みんな平気で親に悪口言ってるでしょう
親がなかったら生きていられないし
親が死ぬ思いで子供のこと心配して育てたのに
これで何やもう14歳になってくると
もうあっち行きなさい
自我があまりにも強すぎになっちゃって
思い出すと困ると自分が
という人間なんです だから我々はエゴの強烈さからも都合の悪いものは忘れちゃう
でも欠点があります 都合の悪いものも同じ法則で覚えちゃう
例えば何か失敗したところで
何か恥をかいたところで
これは強烈にそれだけ覚えちゃうと
それで自己破壊になるんです
だから仏教は治療的に
やっぱりできるだけ良いことだけ覚えておきなさい
人の恩恵だけを覚えておきなさい
人にもくたくたに殴られても
殴られてから その人は冷たいタオルでも出してくれたら
それを覚えておきなさい
あいつは一概に悪いやつではありませんと
だって冷たいタオルくれたんじゃないかと
それだけを覚えなさい
あいつにくたくたに殴られたところは忘れてなさいと
それでいい人間になります
しかし 過去生を思い出しているケースがありますよ
でも本は持ってますけど
いくつかのケースはもういろいろ調べてまとめている
これじゃない この輪廻に対して
このリバースエクスプレインという
これ スリランカの仏教出版社から出している本で
グノラットさんという人が書いている本で
この人は元裁判官なんです
で それからいろんな研究している転生っていうのは現代知識では説明できるのかという
で まあ私は全然参考にしてないんで
私にとってはちょっと内容が古いんです
で 1980年の本で 当時で我々の若い頃はかなりスリランカでも人気があって
爆発的にもういろんな方法で輪廻っていうのは本当あるのかっていう
もう研究してみましょうということで
アメリカのジョンスティーブンという教授と一緒になって
心理学的にいろんな方面で研究したんです
それでいろんなところで過去生を思い出してる人間も見つかるんです
大体子供の時は思い出す場合あるんです
その場合は子供が何言ってるか全部データ取って
ある知識人のグループが
で 密かにそのデータが合ってるかと
この過去を調べてみて
それは調べてみる あるいはあるインドの女の人が
自分がどこかでなんとか名前で生まれていたんだという人
ケースこちら書いてますけど
言って それデータ取って
では合わせてみましょうと
過去の人と今のちっちゃな女の子で
過去はおばさんで死んじゃったんだからね
そこでインドって言ったら
もう自分で勝手に正しい駅で降りて
で 何か車に乗ったところで
あんた道案内しなさいと言ったら
何のことなく この初めて子供が行った土地なんですけど
前自分が行ってた家までちゃんと案内して
あのおじいさんたちをちゃんと発見
あんたあれではあんたこれではないかとかね
みんな見事に当たったとというデータを集めて
だからこのケースだけだったら
この女の子が過去生であのおばさんでいたということになるんではないかというケースを集めて
全部じゃない それだけ集めて書いてる本もまたいくつかあります
イアン・スティーブンさんも自分でもいくつか研究論文を出してるんです
あの心理学さんの先生たちは結構やってます
それからこのヒプノシsmという暗示方法でも
レグレーションという過去に思い出され
過去を思い出させるやり方でも出してますけど
あんまり私はあのやり方は好きじゃないんです
でも誘導的ではないかと
あんまり誘導的も難しいと
それも という  私にとっては個人的な人気がないんだから
これは一応参考にしない
このお話には研究レポートもあります
しかし 誰かが過去生を正しく思い出しても
それで輪廻転生を普遍的な法則として証明したことになりません
これ 私の反論なんです
こういう研究には 誰かさんが誰かさんが過去生を思い出してるんだと言ったってもね
普遍的にすべての生には輪廻転生するんだという証拠になりません
万が一思い出すことができても
それは過去生の人間が今世でも人間で生まれた時に限るのです
過去生で犬だったらどうやって思い出せるんですかね
思考が違うんだから だから人間が死んで人間になったケースの場合だけ
もしかすると思い出せる
仏教の輪廻転生論は すべての生命は転生するという話です
仏教は科学的なみたいな普遍的なことを言っちゃえば
生命は転生する 犬でも猫でも虫でもミミズでも誰でも関係ないんだと
生命であるならば 生命も人間と動物だけに限ったものではない
また 難しいことっていうのは
仏教の生命論では 生命といえば動物
人間だけだと思ったら
それは大違い まだ我々知られ知らない生命はいくらでもいるんです
だからその中でも転生が起こるのです
はい これからでっかい早く飛ばします
様々な それで輪廻転生を仮にでも認めるならば
まああれは皆様も結構苦労しないとわからないんで
今までの説明は 瞑想でもして心は別に働くものだと発見しないと
無常論はわからない 難しいんですが
一応仮に信じてみたらどうなるのかと
様々な特典があります
なぜ一人一人が違いますかと説明がつく
人間っていうのは違うでしょ
犬も一匹一匹違うでしょ
ミミズも一匹一匹違うでしょ
その生命が即 自分の行為に責任を持つことになる
うかつに行動できなくなります
何よりも道徳倫理は大事になる
だから何としてでも食っちゃえばいいっていう話じゃないんです
何としてでも金儲かればいいっていうのは
今の世界そうでしょう
いえ 何よりも道徳が大事だよと
いい人間になることは大事だよ
たまたま金がなくなって貧乏になっちゃってもね
どうったことはないんだと
なぜならばもう輪廻転生するんだから
これとても危険なことやということで
道徳が優先になるんです
不平不満を呟くことがなくなる
なんだ 不平不満ばっかり言いながらいるんじゃなくて
頑張ればいいんですよ
強者の傲慢さがなくなる
あんた今威張ったっても
それからひどい目に遭いますよということになります
弱者の惨めさもなくなります
弱者はなんで私はこんなに不幸なのかと惨めになるんじゃないんですよ
どうせ変わるもんだからね
はい 人格向上は必要な可能なものになる
無常論でだけ我々のは向上できるんです
変化するんだから 魂論が持ってくると全部非宗教的になっちゃうんです
無気力で流れるままで生きることは消える
より活発的で道徳的で生きることになる
世の中が平和になる もう簡単に人殺しはしないことになります
弱者を助ける人間になる
弱者を馬鹿にするんじゃなくて
助けることになります
で 無常を認める人になるから
証券者になる これは仏教的に証券者になります
邪見がなくなります 霊魂の存在を強引に認めさせて弱者を搾取している宗教から解放される
それはありがたいことだと思います
無常論の考え方 はい 次に行きます
それから作尊のメッセージ
今まで輪廻のことを言いましたけど
輪廻転生がありがたくないのです
輪廻はしますよ 無常だから終わらないんだから
でも決してありがたい話じゃないんですよ
飽き飽きするんですよ
どこまでですか？どこまで変化するんですか？どこまで苦しまなくちゃいけないのか
何としてでも乗り越えるべきです
輪廻は いわゆる輪廻しないでくれっていう話ですよ
お釈迦様は言うに 転生は苦難の転生なのです
心の平安 解脱 涅槃を体験するべき
すべての現象に対する執着をなくすべきですっていうのはブッダの教えなんです
だから仏教は輪廻転生を商売道具にしたわけじゃないんです
それはなくせなさいよ
っていうことです はい
もうそろそろ終わりと思います
また作尊のメッセージ
お釈迦様は悟り開いてから
その喜びをこういう風に唱えたんです
アネーカジャーティ サンサーラン サンダーヴィッサン マニッビサン ガハカーラカン ガウェーサン トゥ ドゥッカ ジャーティ プナックプナン
無数の生まれ変わりという輪廻を果てしなくさまよっていたのです
悟ってからこう言うんで
私はもう限りなくさまよっていた
家というのは体 生まれること
命ですね の作者を探し求めて
なぜなら再び生まれることは苦である
輪廻はこりごりやと だから私はもうさまよって
探して探して なんで生まれるのか
なんで生まれるのかとずっと探していたんだよと
はい ガハカーラカ ディットー シー プナゲーハン カハシー
大喜よ 難持を見つけたのです
難持に再び家 生まれを作れないのだ
もうできませんと サッバーテーパース
また間違いあります サッバーテーパースカ バッガ ガハ クータン ヴィサンキタン ヴィサンカーガタン チッタン タンハナンカイ マッジェガ
家っていうのを再生すること
作るために必要なこの梁っていうのは煩悩ですね
梁を壊し 上が入ってないんです
もうあれはどう読むんですかね
次の漢字は 辞書から来たんですけど
え？まあとにかく梁を元につなげてるようなやつですからね
屋根の上で そういうところですね
それは無明と読んで それは壊したのです
もう屋根にしているのは
昔はもう屋根で家だからね
現代建築ではね 屋根はそんなにも大事ではないんですけどね
でも日本でも古い建築になってくると屋根ですよ
結局は これ壊しちゃうと
もう大工さんがお手上げなんです
現象から離れた心が渇愛の滅尽
涅槃を得たのです お釈迦様があの心がどうしてもイライラして
もうもう巡礼したいんですよ
そこはもう無明だからね
それ壊しちゃったんで
それで巡礼が終わっちゃったんです
これは涅槃と呼ぶんです
だからお釈迦様が自分の勝利をそういう言葉で勝利宣言するんです
一応 お釈迦様の最初の言葉だと言われている言葉なんです
悟ってから でまあ そこら辺で一旦終わりますが
ちょっと続けて もし 一旦
一般論的なところはそれで終了します
もう一回  はい